البحث عن الحياة في الفضاء الخارجي
أصبح أكثر إثارة قليلاً
يعتقد العلماء أنهم وجدوا للتو مكانًا جديدًا
للبحث عن الحياة في الكون ،
يسمى الكوكب الخارجي المكتشف حديثًا روس 128 بي
وهو على بعد 11 سنة ضوئية فقط
مما يجعله كونيًا.
يعتقد العلماء الجارون أن الكوكب الخارجي
بحجم الأرض وأنه قد يتواجد في
منطقة Goldilocks للنجم المضيف ، وهو
نجم قزم أحمر صغير يُدعى Ross 128
مما يعني أن جميع ظروف
الحياة لتزدهر يمكن أن تكون مناسبة تمامًا
لدعم الحياة مثل امتلاك
درجة حرارة معتدلة بحيث يمكن أن تتجمع المياه السائلة على
سطح الكوكب الآن لدى
العلماء الكثير لتعلمه قبل أن
يحددوا ما إذا كان روس 128 موجودًا في
المنطقة الصالحة للسكن ، لكن الكثير يأملون في
ضوء ما يعرفونه بالفعل عن
الأقزام الحمراء والكواكب التي تدور حولهم
ترى اللون الأحمر  الأقزام هي أكثر
أنواع النجوم شيوعًا في مجرة درب التبانة بالإضافة إلى أر
عها وأضعفها مما يسمح لن
باكتشاف الكواكب التي تدور حولها.  تم
اكتشاف كوكب خارج المجموعة الشمسية على بعد 4.2 سنة
ضوئية في المنطقة الصالحة
للسكن لنجم قزم أحمر Proxima
Centauri وبينما قد يكون هذا الكوكب
أقرب إلى الأرض ، فإن المثير بشكل
خاص للعلماء حول Ross 128 B
هو أن نجمه المضيف يبدو جيدًا جدًا
تصرف بمعنى أنه لا يسرع
توهجات إيدلي من الأشعة فوق البنفسجية والأشعة السينية
مثل النجوم الأخرى مما يعني أن روس 128
بي يمكن أن يكون مكانًا أكثر راحة
للحياة لتشكيل علماء الفلك اكتشفوا روس 128
بي باستخدام أداة صيد الكواكب
تسمى القيثارات يأمل العلماء في ذلك  مزيد من
الدراسة للكوكب باستخدام
التكنولوجيا القادمة في سعيهم للعثور على
2.0
أنت